the academy awards is treating it like
they don't know what happened they have
opened an investigation
an investigation what the the academy
awards didn't see will smith stand up
and smack a comedian in the head we're
opening an investigation was on that
team
oh actually they hired me to investigate
and the first thing i'm going to do is
look at the videotape that i saw
and i'll investigate i'm going to
investigate mr stern you seem very very
intelligent you've had a long career we
want you to investigate the will smith
incident and i said to them of course i
will and um my entire investigation is
on my tevo i just watched the tape three
times like the supruder film and uh
here's what happened will smith
assaulted another human being and you
guys did nothing i'll tell you if i ever
present an oscar i'm going to wear a
suit of armor
i'd come out in a giant shark cage you
know those tanks
yeah keep the sharks away
and then i would um i would do a whole
monologue and have will smith sit in the
front row and as he's trying to attack
me
i'd be like in my shark tank the academy
said they would take the appropriate
action
based on their bylaws
and i said well what kind of punishment
can the academy meet out
it was in bizarro world i would have
made a citizen's arrest excuse me uh i'm
officer stern i'm uh arresting you i
mean everyone acted like it was
perfectly normal he sits back down in
like uh robert de niro and cape fear
sits back down and starts laughing again
[Laughter]
like he's having a grand old time like
what just happened was nothing like that
that didn't really happen and now all
the other award shows are feeling the
tremendous pressure of having to pull
off crazy [ __ ] to compete with the
oscars uh-oh
yeah the grammys are coming up and um
it's gotta be gonna hit who
kanye and j and pete davidson will
present it